Hey how it's going bros, my name is PewDiePie (subscribe ples)
Ooh, today we're playing three free games even though Pewds doesn't want to play games anymore (subscribe
What a massive fucking fa- (subscribe)
Hey! No! Stop! Stop! (subscribe)
Go away! (subscribe)
You know what? Fine. I'll play games, if that's what you want. (subscribe)
Who am I not to cater to my fanbase (subscribe)
Listen I've gotta get those views up somehow (subscribe)
Oh boy have I collected some of the finest games from the northest west to the southest east
The first ga- the first game is called "Calm Down Stalin"
It's a game about killing yourself which I think seems pretty appropriate
HEY! HEY! Stalin here, what can I do for you?
Place hand- woah ahhh
I'm going to kill myself, I swear I will do it
How do I switch hand? Okay, you switch hand by clicking, right?
My god that fucking...
The closer your hand is to the button, the higher is the effect
Ay listen up mother fucker, do you think I'm smiling?
No, my face do not change
I am always this face
Don't think I won't press the button, 'cause I will press the button
That's it... that's it HA!
Now I will smoke
Ah that feels good! I've become German now
AHHHH
What the f-
This is so bad! Maybe I'm just bad
Hey you think I won't press this fucking button, you see me? You think I won't fucking press this button?
Hail Hydra
I've got Obama on the cell right here
My Russian accent is fucking horrific. You think I won't fucking call? Oh I almost dropped it on the button
That's how much fucking business I mean
What the fuck happened there, go back phone
*They ask you "How are you" and you just have to say that you're fine but you're not really fine*
You think I won't press the fuc- hey come back here you fucking phone. Who is it?!
*Hugh Mungus*
Fuck you.
SHIT!
No I think I'm the be- worst best lets-player of this game in the entire universe thank you very much
Think it's time to move on to the next game aren't you excited we get to play more than one game how about that?
Now this game I really really really really wanna play. A lot. Like genuinely I would play this in my spare time
Probably with Marzia, probably that's a lie but still I'm really excited
I'm really excited
I'm real, I'm real
I'm really I'm really I'm really I'm really
I'm really excited
*reach for the lasers*
Okay here we go ALIEN INVASION
Awh don't tell me we missed it
OOOOOOOHHHH
Sign me in if that's the resu- ohhh shit
Oh my! Bad Ass Babes - Press start. Oh my god there's so much fucking shi-
Is that a dragon coming out of her tits?
Oh my fucking god
Do we select a character? I guess we go with the naked one
Oh she's twerking, fantastic. Trapped in green slime and experimented on for months
Here we are. Wow what a great game. Oh boy!
Her name is "Asia". Now that's, that's, that's nothing wrong with that
Ah shit they've got my sisters!
Ah all the hot babes are in this game. Oh this is just the greatest game I've ever played
Wow look how many hot babes this game has. OH IT'S MYSTIC
OH I LOVE MYSTIC she's so hot
Take this alien scum. Oh shit it's right in my fucking face
It's got claws and shit. No no no NO!
Best fucking use of green screen I have ever seen
OH! Oooooooooooooohhhhhhhh
I don't think I was ready for that
Oh my special move
I'm really having a good time over here this is really fun I'm really really enjoying myself
I think it's a good game it's got good graphics
It looks up to standard with any Call of Duty game I mean...
What can you complain about in a game like this I just really think it's a good game I don't know
Does it have tits in the background? Yes it does that doesn't mean it's not a good game okay
I mean that doesn't mean we should take it less seriously
If anything it just makes it better 'cause you just add tits to things and it just gets ehh it just gets ehh it just gets
It just... SHOOT OUT OF A PUSSY
I think that's about enough of that game
Thank you so much for all the hard work that went into that. I really really like games
OKAY the last game - "Make America Great Again"
Okay. OH MY GOD I'm so cute. Look at this shit!
Oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh terrorists!
What the fuck?!
One fucking bullet hits me and I'm dead?!
You know Trump really gets down to business and you've gotta respect that
Oh, you've gotta jump over the bullets
See, I didn't know that
*swedish curse words*
Listen if touching barbed wire with your fucking feet kills you...
Then maybe you don't deserve to be president. Alright here we go
I can't even jump that far!
Damn barbed wire! Come on we can do this
Come on. Come on Trump!
Come on Trump! No!
Shit, no!
OOOOOOOOOOHH THAT'S RIGHT BARBED WIRE YOU CAN'T STOP FREEDOM
Oh shit this is gonna be hard
Oh fuck
Are you serious? Are you fucking kidding me
How the fuck am I gonna do that
*more swedish curse words*
*erotic noises*
HOOOOO, *screaming*
OH MY GOD
*inaudible* ooh
WHAT?!
Why do I care? Why do I care?
This is stupid I don't care
Fuck that game
Fucking hell
You fucking... you fucking tell 'em
You fucking tell... you tell 'em
Alright, here we go, come on
Vote for Trump because Hilary is gay
OOOOOHHH
Oh hey I bet you thought the video was over
10 minutes
No but for real I watched through the video
And it doesn't have a single good game in it
So I thought hey lets put in a good game
that you bros can play as well at home
and not because I want this video to be 10 minutes long
Okay maybe both, maybe both, is that so fucking bad?
You're gonna see a lot of YouTubers play this game, they're gonna make a full episode of it
Drag that shit out
Nothing wrong with that, I can respect that
If you go to damn.dog, there's this really funny website that lets you guess
what the Wiki How is
compared to the image. Now if you don't know what wikiHow is it's basically a website that
will explain fucking anything.
Here if I search wikiHow pewdiepie
How to build a fucking channel
How to be a fangirl
Alright and they always have these fucking pictures
We're gonna guess together what it is. How to...
Get your nipples pierced
Now that's probably not it
I'm gonna have to go with...
Yes
Thats RIGHT!
Hey this is actually pretty fun I should probably make a full version of this
Is that Scooby Doo? How to get over a crush on your best friend
How to buy firearms... How to be interesting
Okay it seems like I have a natural talent for this
How to tell a girl you like her
Smoking tricks for sure. Yeah yeah yeah. I know that one
That's called the Chinese Dragon
Look it up. Fart Quietly
Ayyyyyyy
What's in the title of this wikiHow article?
How to get famous while young. Famous
It seems like I'm really good at this
How to act like Sonic the Hedgehog
This is only fun because of the things
Okay husband that you love him. That's it yeah?
How to stop staring at a girl's boobs
Woah that must be it. HEY!
What is the title of this wikiHow article?
You know what I really enjoyed this one maybe I'll make a full episode maybe I'll play it together with someone
But yeah that's it from me for now, hope you enjoyed four free games with pewds
Let me know which one you enjoyed the most, leave a like if you enjoyed watching.
And as alwayz..
Stay awesome bros.
Caption credits to: iVexusHD and Sukrut Nadigotti